hu
[Applaudissements]
les réactions 17 patrick bourgeois sont
à la mesure du succès qu'il a connu avec
les bébés au tournant des années 90
françois jean le batteur du groupe est
toujours sous le choc
moi j'ai beaucoup de gratitude pour la
locomotive qui l'a été avec pour les
bébés le de bénéficier de son génie
mélodique
[Musique]
le succès le préfet l'ex remporté les
spectacles le passage en france le
claviériste du groupe alain lapointe a
connu la gloire avec patrick bourgeois
il retient surtout de l'homme son talent
s'est réduit à la limite du sud où il
c'est un personnage quand même à
imposant mais qui qui faisant en sorte
qu'on avait le goût de sauter avec lui
parce que les instances de diamètre sens
de l'humour un sens de la répartie
complètement foule
[Applaudissements]
la salle est ton café
ludovic le fils de patrick bourgeois
tient de son père il a remporté la
finale de la téléréalité la voix en mai
dernier il a réagi au décès de son père
sur sa page facebook en soulignant lui
aussi son humour
l'animatrice geneviève borne a suivi la
carrière du groupe
en plus d'être une amie de patrick
bourgeois je suis très mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de sourire quand je pense à
lui parce que jusqu'à la fin il reste
aideront est resté sympathique c'est
comme un sentiment de ok ben ça devrait
passer dans nos vies qui a été un rayon
de soleil a été une lumière
il nous a transmis de la joie et c'est
peut-être ça qui est le plus important
au final
ici mélanie boissonneault radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
je suis marié